Benim secik 9 sınıf öim jf fakulta
okuluna YouTube'un en büyük jf kanalına
Hepiniz hoş geldiniz zedo öğretmenleri
ile beraber yaptığımız okula destek
kapımızın bugün geldik 20 gününe Gençler
bugün sizinle beraber nüfus
piramitlerini öğreneceğiz bu konu
yazılıda çıkan bir konudur bırakın
yazılı da çıkmasını üniversite sınavının
bile en önemli konularından bir
tanesidir O yüzden bu konuyu can
kulağıyla dinleyeceksin bu konu anlatım
olarak Bu videoda olacak aynı zamanda
soru çözümü de bu videoda olacak
videonun ik kısmında sorular çözeceğiz O
soruları çözmeden bu konuyu geçme çünkü
bu konu sorular üzerinden Anlaşılan bir
konu diyoruz ben kalemi aldım hazırım
Sen de beğen tuşuna basıp abone olarak
kazandıysan o zaman ne diyoruz Yunus
hoca la bir defa öğren bir daha asla
unutma zedu ile eğitim her yerde geldik
demografik dönüşüm süreci modeli ve
nüfus piramitlerini öğreneceğiz bu pdf'i
gençler zedu van.com sitesinden ücretsiz
bir şekilde indirebilirsiniz bize
pdf'ler imizi Paraf Yayınları sağlıyor
hem de bakın renkli bir şekilde
indirmenize de izin veriyor Bu imkanları
sağladığı için ben sizin adınıza da
Paraf yayınlarına teşekkür ediyorum
gençler bakın nüfus piramidi dediğimiz
şey ne biliyor musunuz ülkeler nüfusları
öyle Durağan değildir yani hareketlidir
nüfusları bazı dönemlerde çok fazla
doğum olur Bazı dönemlerde doğumlar
azalır yaşlılar artmaya başlar bazı
dönemlerde ne bileyim ortanca yaş Aktif
nüfus iyice artar Bütün bunlar bir
dönüşümdür Aslında bu dönüşüm ülke
nüfusunu
tanımlayabilmek anlayabilmemiz için
piramitlerle karşımıza çıkıyor
piramitlerden Okumaya çalışıyoruz biz
ülke nüfusu hakkında bilgileri ülke
nüfusu hakkında yorumlamalar
yapabiliyoruz piramitlerle bu
piramitlerin mantığı nedir hocam Peki
niye böyle bir piramit yapmışlar yani
nüfusu burada nasıl gösteriyor ki bize
Bakın şimdi Gençler bu böyle bir
piramidin mantığı şu buraya yaşları
sıralıyor şöyle demişler Ya biz bu
yaşları bir tane çizgiye koymamız lazım
görebilmek için yaşları sıralayalım Ya
bunu böyle yatay sıral Sak olmayacak o
zaman Ne yapalım demişler demişler ki en
mantıklısı şöyle sıfırdan başlayalım
Idan başlayıp yukarıya kadar çıkar bakın
90 Art diyor bu aralar yaş aslında ha
demişler O zaman 0dan başlayıp yukarı
doğru çıkan bir yaş dizilimi yapalım
tamam peki bu yaş dizilimini yaparken e
burada kadınları da erkekleri de
ayıralım daha iyi ayrıntılı bilgi
öğrenmiş oluruz o sıralamayı yaparken de
bakın 04 yaş demiş ya 04 yaşın kadın
pembeyle göstermiş kadınları sağ tarafa
koymuş maviyle göstermiş erkekleri sol
tarafa koymuş Böylece yaş gruplarına
göre bir sıralama yapmış yukarı doğru
kadınlar bir tarafa erkekler bir tarafa
işte yavaş yavaş piramidim ortaya
çıkıyor Buna niye nüfus piramitleri
demişler nüfus kareleri olsun Ne bileyim
nüfus grafikleri olsun Hani niye nüfus
piramidi Çünkü Gençler bu piramitlerin
şu alt kısmı bize doğumları göstermez mi
mesela şurası 04 yaş saa O zaman ben bu
piramidin alt kısmına bakarak ne kadar
insan doğduğunu ne kadar çocuk doğduğunu
görebilirim değil mi E üst kısmı da bana
yaşlıları gösterir E tamam E Şimdi
mantıken Düşünsenize çocuklar doğdu
insanlar yavaş yavaş ölecek ölmeye
başlıyorlar bakın 65 yaştan sonra
ölümler artıyor 90 yaşa geldiğinde bir
daralma oluyor yani ölüm diye bir şey
olduğu için Aslında piramit üste
çıktığında Yani bu şekil üste çıktığında
daralıp ucu kapanıyor ucunun
kapanmasının nedeni insanların ölmesi
bir süre sonra artık işte 120 yaşına
geldiğinde Mesela kimse yok sıfır sıfır
olduğu için piramit oluşuyor yani o
şeklin ucu kapanıyor insanlar öldüğü
için ve ortaya piramit çıkıyor ölüm diye
bir şey olmasaydı gençler O zaman şöyle
giderdi bakın o zaman şöyle giderdi Ölüm
Diye Bir Şey İnsanlar ölmeseydi o zaman
ortaya bir piramit çıkmazdı şöyle bir
şekil çıkardı ortaya O zaman biz buna
piramit demek demezdik Demek ki bizim
piramit şeklinin ortaya çıkmasının
nedeni temelde insanların ölmesi ve
piramidin giderek daralması ve şeklin
ortaya çıkmasına neden oluyor buradaki
mantığı Anladık mı ha piramidin temel
mantığını anladıysan Şimdi gelelim iç
kısmına gençler bakın piramidin şu 014
yaş arasındaki kısmına bunun altını çiz
çocuk nüfus denir Sen şimdi 9 sınıfsın
büyük bir ihtimalle 014 yaş arasındasın
Sen çocuk nüfus içer içerisine
giriyorsun Aslında Tamam bu yaş
gruplarını bilmemiz lazım Neden Çünkü
bize sorularda soracak çocuk nüfus bir
ülkede fazlaysa ne olur diye Ha demek ki
şu alt kısım çocuk nüfus Eğer bu alt
kısım fazlaysa şöyle diyoruz biz Ha o
zaman burada doğumlar fazla şu alt
kısmın fazla olduğu yerler oluyor şöyle
oluyor piramit gençler ya o kadar fazla
oluyor ki Alt kısım O zaman diyoruz ki
biz burada doğumlar fazla diyoruz mantık
bu tamam mı Sonra bir üst kısma bakın 14
yaşın üstüne çıkıyoruz ya artık
1565 yaş arası Buna da Aktif nüfus
deniyor Yani çalışma çağında buradaki
insanlar yani şu arası bakın 64 yaşla 15
yaşın şu arasındaki Bunlar Aktif nüfus
çalışan nüfus 10 11 sınıfa geçtiğinizde
Aslında Siz aktif nüfusa geçiyorsunuz
Aktif nüfus içerisindesiniz ama
okuduğunuz için çalışmıyorsunuz Aslında
Anlaştık mı Aktif nüfus da bu gelelim
şimdi yaşlı nüfusa gençler bakın 65 yaş
ve üstü nüfusa da yaşlı nüfus diyoruz
biz bunun altını çiz bunlar önemli Şu
altını çizdiklerim var ya bunların
notunu al bunlar önemli Bunu verip sana
bunları ayırman da isteyebilir hocam
senden aynı buradaki yaş gruplarına
Demek ki 65 yaşın üstüne de biz yaşlı
nüfus diyoruz bakın görüyor musunuz
yaşlı nüfus giderek burada azalmış Bir
ülkede yaşlı nüfus fazlaysa Biz o ülkeye
gençler gelişmiş ülke diyoruz Çünkü
Nijerya gibi ülkelerde bunu örnek
vererek anlatayım size nijerya'yı
düşünelim Nijerya gibi Somali gibi
ülkelerde çok fazla doğum olur değil mi
Herkes 8 tane 10 tane çocuk yapıyor O
zaman piramidin altı nasıl olacak
mantıken altı geniş olacak ama Nijerya
gibi ülkelerde ölümler fazla insanlar
çabuk ölüyor o zaman piramidin üstü
hızla daralacak yani Nijerya gibi
gelişmemiş ülkelerde yaşlı nüfus
nasıldır azdır değil mi insanlar ölüyor
çünkü çocuk nüfus fazladır Almanya'yı
Bir de düşünelim bu somutlamaya
yapabilmeniz lazım Almanya gibi
ülkelerde ise He Almanya'da çok çocuk
yapmıyor insanlar O zaman çocuk nüfus az
ama Almanya gibi ülkelerde sağlık
imkanları fazla İyi o zaman insanlar
ölmüyor o kadar kolay kolay o zaman
Almanya gibi ülkelerde de yaşlı nüfus
fazla olmuş oluyor buradaki mantığı
Anladık mı piramitlerdeki mantık budur
gençler Yani biz Aslında böyle bir
piramide baktığımızda nüfusun artışını
yaş gruplarına göre dağılımını görüyoruz
değil mi 15 yaş dedik 64 yaş dedik yaş
gruplarına göre dağılımı cinsiyetini
kadın erkek görebiliyoruz o piramide
baktığımızda sosyoekonomik durum
hakkında ya da gelişmişlik düzeyi
hakkında yorum yapabiliyoruz bir
piramide bakarak yaşlılar çok fazlaysa a
Burası gelişmiş ülke çocuklar çok
fazlaysa a Burası az gelişmiş ülke
diyoruz bak gelişmişlik hakkında yorum
yap piramidin temel mantığını Anladık mı
Tamam Kadın erkeğe söyledik Bir de
piramidin bir mantığı var onu da
söyleyeyim size gençler bakın piramide
dikkat ederseniz Ne diyor burada kişi
sayısı milyon diyor kişi sayısı bazen
böyle milyon kişi olarak gösterilir bize
kişi miktar olarak gösterilir böyle
bakın burada nasıl miktar olarak
gösterilmiş Ama bazen de yüzde olarak
gösterilir oran olarak gösterilir şimdi
ikisi arasında fark oluşuyor Neden Çünkü
bize kişi verdiği zaman Bakın bu
piramitte nasıl verilmiş kişi verilmiş O
zaman ben bakıyorum şurada 04 yaş
arasında 10 milyon kız var kadın varmış
10 milyon erkek varmış o zaman 04 yaş
arasında ne derim 20 milyon kişi vardır
derim değil mi o zaman işte diğerinde de
20 diğerinde de 18 derken ben bu ülkenin
nüfus miktarını bulabilir miyim nüfus
miktarını Evet bulabilirim Çünkü tek tek
bana kaç milyon kişi olduğunu vermiş
bunların hepsini toplarım nüfus
miktarını bulurum Hatta burada çocuk
çağındaki Nüfusun miktarını da bulurum
hepsini toplayıp yaşlı çağındaki Nüfusun
miktarını da bulurum bu ne zaman
bulunabiliyor gençler bize kişi sayısı
şeklinde verdiğinde ama bize kişi sayısı
vermeyip Bize sadece yüzde vermiş
olsaydı oran vermiş olsaydı oransal
piramit olsaydı o zaman bunu bulamıyoruz
neden E çünkü bana demiş ki % 10'u kadın
% 110'u erkek Ee tamam % 110'u da kaçın
% 10'u 100 milyonun mu 500 milyonun mu
kaçın % 10'u kadın % erkek oran
verdiğinde kişi yorumu miktar yorumu
yapamıyoruz buradaki mantığı Anladınız
mı Ama burada oran verip bu ülkede 100
milyon kişidir dese o zaman bunu
oranların bulursun ama burada miktar
vermediği sürece oran verdiğinde miktar
yorumu yapamıyoruz buradaki piramitte bu
püf noktayı unutma Bu soruların
gelebileceği piramit yorumlamadaki
birinci kısımda şimdi geliyoruz gençler
demografik dönüşüm modeline ne demek
Hocam bu demografik dönüşüm modeli şu
gençler bunu Almanya İngiltere gibi
sanayileşmiş ülkelerin geçmişten
günümüze nasıl bir dönüşüm yaşadığını
verilerek ortaya çıkarmışlar yani
bakmışlar ki işte Almanya'nın
İngiltere'nin sanayileşmeden önceki
halinden sanayileşme süreci sonrasına
kadar olan dönüşümleri böyle Buna da
demografik dönüşüm modeli demişler
buradaki mantık ne biliyor musunuz bakın
şöyle aşama aşama gidelim en gelişmemiş
halden en gelişmiş ülkeye doğru gidiyor
bu aşamalar yani şu bir ülke şu
haldeyken en gelişmemiş ülke oluyor
Neden biliyor musunuz Çünkü burada
Piramidi okumayı öğren bunu anlatacağım
sana piramide bakıyorum piramidin altına
bakar mısınız piramidin altı tabanı çok
geniş ne demek bu ha hocam burada
doğumlar çok fazla Demek ki diyeceksin
Ha o zaman böyle piramitler verip yorum
istiyor senden ha burada doğumlar
fazlaysa Burası gelişmemiş diyorsun
nereden Anladım doğumların fazla
olduğunu Bakın bakın burada oransal
vermiş Piramidi görüyor musunuz 8 % ve
şuraya bakın taban çok geniş doğumlar
çok fazla insanlar 810 tane çocuk
yapıyor doğumlar çok fazla bakın ne
diyor doğumlar yüksek ama ölümler de
yüksek nereden anlıyorum ya şimdi bakın
bu Çocuklar burada doğmuş ya hemen
ölmeye başlıyorlar bakın yani 15 yaşına
kadar gidememiş bakın % doğmuş % 5'i
falan % 5'i falan 15 yaşına
gidebilmektedir
[Müzik]
anlıyorum çünkü piramit yukarı
çıkıldıkça içeri doğru göçüyor Yani bu
ne demek insanlar hızla ölüyor bakın 65
yaşına geldiğinde yüzde kaçı kalmış %
2'si kalmış ya burada % hani buradaki %
6 nereye gitmiş 60 yaşına kadar
yaşayamamış Demek ki burası hiç
gelişmemiş bir ülke diyeceksin mantık
budur gençler Tamam bakıyorum doğumlar
fazla ölümler de çok fazla piramit içeri
göçmüş yaşlı nüfusa bakar mısınız
Piramidi okuyabilmem için ilk önce iki
tane şeye bakacaksınız bir tanesi
doğumlara bir tanesi yaşlılara doğumlar
çok fazla yaşlılar hiç yok neredeyse
hepsi ölmüş yaşlıların neredeyse Demek
ki doğumlar ve ölümlerin çok fazla
olduğu gelişmemiş ülke Piramidi bu en
eski ülkelerin en eski en gelişmemiş
versiyonları bu birinci piramit Ama bu
ülke yavaş yavaş gelişmeye başlayabilir
bu ülke de gençler iki tane sorun var
Bakın bu sorunları bilirseniz yavaş
yavaş düzelmeye de anlarsınız iki tane
sorun var Bir tanesi doğumların fazla
olması E bir tanesi de ölümlerin fazla
olması Şimdi sen doğumları hemen
azaltamıyorum 8 tane çocuk yapıyor hemen
azaltın bunları diyemezsin bir süreç
gerek ama sen sağlık imkanlarını biraz
biraz iyileştirmeye başladığında ölümler
azalmaya başlar ölümler azalmaya
başlarsa ne olur ikinci piramide
geçersin gençler bakın ölümler fazlayken
piramit içeri göçüydüm ne demekti
insanlar hızlıca ölüyor Peki ölümleri
azaltmaya başlarsan ne olur bak ölümleri
azaltırsan piramit yavaş yavaş düzgün
bir piramide dönmeye başlar bunun
kenarları içe Çökük piramit Aradaki fark
bu kenarları içe Çökük ölümler çok fazla
bu tarafa geliyorum ölümleri azaltmaya
başlarsam kenarların içe çöküklüğü yavaş
yavaş düzelmeye başlar ve karşımıza
ikinci piramit çıkar ikinci piramit
özelliği düzgün üçgen Piramidi Bakın bu
düzgün bir üçgen var burada Ne olmuş
burada ölümler azalmış Bak bu sefer ne
diyor doğum oranları hala Yüksek diyor
Bak burada da nasıldı 8di bak hala 8
doğum oranlarında bir değişim yok
doğumlar hala yüksek ama bak ne diyor
ölüm oranları düşmeye başlamıştır işte
ölüm oranları düştüğü için ülke artık
hafif hafif gelişmeye başlıyor hafif
hafif Gelişmekte olan ülkeye doğru
gitmeye başlıyor ikinci kısma geliyor
düzgün üçgene dönüşüyor buradaki mantığı
anladın mı Evet artık ölümler azaldığı
için piramit düzleşmeye düzgün üçgene
dönmeye başladı gençler Bakın bu iki
tane piramide baktığımızda hangisinde
nüfus artış hızı daha fazladır şimdi
bakın şu piramit var Bir de bu piramit
var hangisinde nüfus artış hızı daha
fazladır şu piramitte ikinci piramitte
nüfus artış hızı daha fazla oluyor Buna
göre daha fazla oluyor Neden Çünkü
burada Tamam çok fazla kişi doğmuş
mesela 8 kişi doğ doğduğunu varsayalım
Tabii ki bu oran ama ben 8 kişi anlayın
diye söylüyorum 8iz kişi doğduğunu
varsayalım E hepsi Çoğu kişi ölmüş ha 8
doğmuş tamam mı 8 değil 10 gösteriyorum
ya şöyle 8 doğmuş bunların 5 tanesi
ölmüş o zaman kaç artarsa 3 artarsa
değil mi bu tarafa bakın 8 doğmuş mu kaç
ölmüş bu sefer bu sefer 3 kişi ölmüş o
kadar fazla kişi ölmemiş ölümler azaldı
Çünkü o zaman burası ölümler azaldığı
için daha fazla artıyor nüfus 5 kişi
artar Yani bu iki piramitten hangisi
daha fazla artmış oluyor bu daha fazla
nüfus artış Hıı daha yüksek oluyor Tamam
mı Şimdi Ama bu ikinci piramitte de bir
sorun var şimdi burada iki tane sorun
vardı bir tanesi ölümler bir tanesi
doğumlarda Ee burada ölümleri düzelttik
ölümleri düzelttik ama bir sorunumuz
devam ediyor doğumlar hala çok fazla o
zaman doğumları azalmaya başlaması lazım
ülke politika izliyor diyor ki Çocuklara
çok fazla Çocuklardan fazla vergi
alacağız çocukları yapmayın gibi
Politikalar izleyince Bu sefer bakın
şuraya bakın doğumlar azalmaya başlıyor
görüyor musunuz İşte bu asimetrik
piramit bir asimetrik bir piramit
çıkıyor ortaya bakın üçgen piramidinden
son yıllarda doğumların azalmaya
başladığı bir asimetrik piramide 3üncü
ülkeye dönüşüyor şöyle 3üncü haline
dönüşüyor birinci aşama ikinci aşama
artık 3üncü aşamaya geldik bu sefer
doğumlar azalmaya başladı ne diyor doğum
Oran hızla azalan ölüm oranlarındaki
düşüşün yavaş olduğu piramit buradaki
mantık ne doğumlar artık azaltı bu iki
ülke Gelişmekte olan ülkeler Özellikle
de şu Gelişmekte olan ülke hala çok
gelişmiş mi hala çok gelişmiş değil
nereden anlıyorum bakın yaşlı nüfus o
kadar fazla değil hala çok gelişmiş bir
ülke değil Çünkü geldim bu sefer gençler
4ün aşamaya şöyle artık 4ün aşamaya
geldik buradaki Bakın bu artık gelişmiş
ülke neden doğumlar az bakın 4 doğumlar
az ama ölümler de az dikkat edin
insanlar bak % 4'ü doğmuş ya o % 4 hemen
hemen 15 yaşına kadar gitmiş ha bak
insanlar öyle hemen ölmüyor yavaş yavaş
ölüyorlar yaşlı nüfusa bakıyorum bayağı
bayağı yaşlı nüfus var ha O zaman burası
gelişmiş ülke diyeceksin işte piramidin
4ün versiyonunda da ülke gelişiyor bu
hale geliyor Bu sefer ne doğumlar da
düşük ölümler de düşük doğumlar da düşük
ölümler de düşük yaşlı nüfusun fazla
genç Nüfusun az olduğu gelişmiş ülke
Piramidi sonra ne oluyor Bir 5 aşama
daha 5 aşamaya geçiyoruz burada ülke
artık ülkenin canını okuyorlar nasıl
canını okuyorlar doğumlar artık çok
ciddi anlamda düşüyor bakın artık şurada
4'ün biraz üstündeydi 4'ün de altına
düşmeye başlıyor bu 4 önemli değil
gençler Bu öylesine verilmiş bir oran bu
8 de olabilir 16 da olabilir yani o 4E
takılmayın Tamam ama doğumlar ne olmuş
bakın anlıyorum Ben şuraya bakın
doğumlar git gide azalıyor bak düşük
doğum oranları yüksek ölüm oranı hocam
yüksek ölüm oranı ne alaka Hani burada
gelişmiş bir ülkeydi gelişmiş bir ülkede
yüksek ölüm olmaz ki Hocam onlar
sağlıklıydı yüksek ölümden kastı ne
biliyor musunuz Şuradaki yaşlılara bakar
mısınız yaşlılara bir bakın resmen yaşlı
patlaması yaşanıyor E bu yaşlılar bir
yerden sonra ölecekler e mecburen yüksek
ölümden kastı bu sağlık imkanlarının
kötü olduğu için yüksek ölüm demiyor
yaşlıların fazla olduğu için yüksek ölüm
diyor bakın Buralar şişmiş resmen artık
ülke yaşlılıktan ölmeye başlıyor e
yaşlılar ölüyor E çok fazla doğum da yok
ülke eksi yazmaya başlıyor nüfus
azalmaya başlıyor artık bu da 5 versiyon
bundan sonra aslında bir versiyon daha
var buraya koymamışlar Ama ben bunu size
anlatayım Bu dönüşüm modelinde
görülmediği için için Ama gelecekte
birçok ülke nüfusunu arttırmaya
çalışıyor ne yapıyor biliyor musunuz
diyor ki ya benim doğumları çok az böyle
olmaz nüfusu arttırıcı yönde politika
izlemem lazım gerekirse çocuk yapanlara
para dağıtmam lazım fazla çocuk
yapanları desteklemem lazım diye
nüfusunu arttırmaya çalışıyor ve sonra
bu piramit gençler şöyle son yıllarda
nüfusun biraz daha olsun artmaya
başladığı bir çana benziyor bak Çan gibi
çanın da altı böyle şeydir ya Bu çın çın
çın çın diye Çan var ya bu çanın altında
Çan gibi hafiften nüfusun son yıllarda
hafiften Nüfus artışının doğumların son
yıllarda hafiften artmaya başladığı bir
model daha var Tamam ama o model öyle
her ülkede görülemiyor şu an Mesela
bizim ülkemizde de ciddi anlamda doğum
oranları düştü nüfusu arttırmaya çalışan
politikalara geçmeye çalışıyoruz Evet bu
da demografik dönüşüm modeliydi şimdi
Şuradaki 6 soru şu 6 soru bakın örnek 6
cevap şu diye yorumlara yazıyorsunuz Ben
bunu çözemiyorum ÖSYM sorusu Bu Az sonra
siz de zaten bol bol soru çözeceğiz
bunun cevabını aşağıda yorumlara yaz Bu
çıkmış bir soru Evet şimdi gelelim
Türkiye'nin dönüşümüne şimdi dedik ya
demografik dönüşüm modeli diye o zaman
Türkiye'nin de bir piramitleri var
geçmiş yıllardan günümüze kadar gelen
bir piramit serisi var bu piramit
serisinde nasıl bir dönüşüm yaşadık buna
bakalım Bakın
1950-1980 şu 1950 1980 görüyor musunuz
Nasıl biraz daha hani o ikinci aşamada
düzgün üçgen vardı ya şöyle bir dakika
ha ikinci aşamada bir dü düzgün üçgen
vardı hani biraz daha ona benziyor bakın
1980'e kadar yani doğumlar yüksek bakın
doğumlar yüksek şöyle ölüm oranları
düşük sağlık imkanları biraz daha
gelişmiş ölüm oranları düşük ikinci
aşamadaki piramide benziyorduk sonra
2000'li yıllara geldiğimizde bakın
şuraya bakın doğum oranlarının düşmeye
başladığı asimetrik bir piramit vardı ya
3ün aşamadaki bir piramit vardı 3ün
aşamadaki hale geliyor Türkiye doğum
oranları 2000'li yıllardan sonra düşmeye
başlıyor gençler sonra 2023'e bakın
şuraya bakın bakın artık giderek bak bak
asimetrik de geçtik artık giderek
doğumlar düşmeye başlıyor Bu da ilk 4ün
aşama bakın şöyle şöyle 4ün aşama ama
şuralar çok tehlikeli yavaş yavaş 5
aşamaya gidiyoruz Şu an 4 aşama
diyebiliriz buna ama yavaş yavaş 5'e
gideceğiz neden 5 değil bu biliyor
musunuz Çünkü bizim ülkemiz o 5te
yaşlılar aşırı derecede şişkin dikkat
edin şurada bakın şurada yaşlılar iyice
şişmişti bizde daha o yaşlılık şişmedi
Hangi açıdan 5'e yaklaşıyoruz doğumların
düşmesi açısından çok ciddi bir sıkıntı
yaşıyoruz Gençler işte tüm Bu sıkıntılar
üzerine devlet ne yapıyor biliyor
musunuz şu an özellikle 2005 yıllarından
sonra devlet nüfus artış hızını
yükseltmeye yönelik Politikalar izlemeye
başlıyor bunu bir sonra sonraki derste
göreceğiz ülkelerin politikalarında şu
an bu çok ciddi bir sorun bizim ülkemiz
için çalışacak insan sayısı
bulamayabilir yıllar sonra çalışacak
insan bulamayabilir bunlar ciddi
problemler bu problemi de İnşallah
çözeriz çocuk sayısı artar diyelim Çünkü
Bu şakaya alınacak bir durum değil
çalışacak kişi bulamayız Evet gelelim
şimdi test sorusu çözümüne Evet Size iki
tane test çözeceğiz Bu konuda bir
ülkedeki ekonomik ve sosyal gelişmelere
göre doğal nüfus artış hızının nasıl
değiştiğini açıklamak için demografik
dönüşüm modeli ortaya konmuştur Bu model
bir ülkenin doğum ve ölüm oranlarına
göre şekillenen mevcut nüfus artışını
dikkate alarak o ülkenin Bu modeldeki
beş gelişim aşamasından hangisinde
olduğunu belirlemeye çalışır Buna göre 5
aşamada yer alan bir ülke ile ilgili
aşağıdakilerden hangisi söylenebilir 5
aşama nasıldı çizelim hemen Biz bunu
şöyle 5 aşama böyle doğumların azaldığı
değil mi doğum oranlarının az olduğu
şöyle yaşı nüfusu fazla olduğu çizdim 5
aşamayı Buna göre yorumlayalım hangisi
söylenebilir doğum ve ölüm oranları
yüksek Hayır doğumlar yüksek değil doğum
oranları yüksek Hayır doğumlar yüksek
değil Burada ölüm oranları düşük Hayır
bakın yaşlı fazla olduğu için ölümler
fazlaydı demiştik doğum oranlarının
hızla azalmasına bağlı olarak Evet doğum
oranları hızla azalıyor nüfus artış hızı
çok düşüktür nüfus artış hızı düşüktür
kelimesi 5 Piramidi karşılamıyor gençler
çünkü nüfus artış hızı düşüktür 4
piramitte eydi 5 piramitte nüfus
azalıyor kelimesi lazım bize nüfus
azalıyor lazım bize 4 piramit bu Ama
bakın 5 e şıkkına genç nüfus oranının az
genç nüfus oranı az yaşlı nüfus oranının
fazla yaşlı nüfus fazla olmasına bağlı
olarak ölüm oranının doğum oranından
biraz daha yüksek olduğundan nüfusta
azalma görülür nüfusta azalma görülür
kelimesini görün ce 5 piramit diyorsun
Bunun püf noktası burasıydı Cevap e
geçelim diğer soruya aşağı grafikte Bir
ülkenin nüfus piramidi verilmiştir
grafikteki bilgilere dayanarak ülke ile
ilgili niteliklerinden hangileri
hakkında bilgi edinilebilir bakın ne
yapmış ülke şöyle gelişmemiş bir ülke di
geçmişte Ama son yıllarda doğumlar
azalmaya başlıyor bakalım çalışan
nüfusun ekonomik faaliyetlere göre
dağılımı Şimdi ben bunların kaç tanesi
sanayide çalışıyor ne kadarı tarımda
çalışıyor böyle ekonomik faaliyet
dağılımını bilebiliyor muyum e piramide
bakarak bulamıyorum Eledim cinsiyet
durumunu bilebilirim Bakın bu tarafta
kadın bu tarafta erkek var bunu buldum
nüfusun eğitim durumunu Evet bu ülkenin
gelişmiş mi gelişmemiş mi olduğu
hakkında kabaca yorum yapabilirim ama %
198 eğitimli % 70 eğitimli gibi böyle
net bir eğitim durumu hakkında böyle net
bir yargıya ulaşamam Nüfusun yaş
gruplarına dağılımını Evet bakın 04 5 9
35 80 yaş gruplarına dağılımını
bulabiliyorum bunu da ulaştım yani 2 ve
4'e ulaştık cevap D geçelim diğer soruya
Yukarıdaki açıklamaya en uygun nüfus
piramidi aşağıdak hangisinde yer
almaktadır az gelişmiş ülkelerde doğum
ve ölüm oranları fazla ortalama yaşam
süresi kısa olduğundan toplam nüfus
içinde genç nüfus oranı çok fazladır bak
Hem doğumlar fazla olacak piramit olacak
hem de ölümler de fazla olacak He o
zaman piramidim içeri doğru göçecek
değil mi doğumlar fazla ama ölümler de
fazla olunca içeri göçüydüm öncesinde
ait bu tür nüfus piramitleri günümüzde
daha çok Angola brundi benin gibi Afrika
ülkelerinde görülür piramidim içeri
göçmesi lazım Bakın şu piramit ve şu
piramit gelişmemiş iki tane 1 ve 2'ydi
ama bize ne diyor yüksek doğum yüksek de
ölüm olacak piramit içeri göçecek diyor
yani cevabımız e şıkkı geçelim diğer
soruya aşağıda iki ülkeye ait nüfus
piramitleri gösterilmiştir bu iki
ülkenin özelliklerinden hangileri
kesinlikle farklıdır bakıyoruz ama bak
Dikkat et kesinliklenin altını çizmiş
nüfusun cinsiyete göre dağılım oranı
cinsiyetler verilmiş ama bu dağılım
oranı kesinlikle farklıdır kesinlikle
dediği için hani bunu buradan çıkartmak
biraz zor gibi geliyor bana cinsiyete
göre dağılım oranı yani yüzdesel olarak
erkek kadın yüzde kaç erkek kadın yüzde
kaç kesinlikle farklıdır direkt
baktığımda yani böyle tam çıkartamadım
Ortalama insan ömrü kesinlikle farklıdır
e bakın yaşlılar Burada fazla yaşlılar
burada yok o zaman Ortalama insan ömrü
kesinlikle farklı doğum oranları bakın
doğum burada az Bak burada az burada
fazla direkt baktığımda bunların
kesinlikle farklı olduğunu görebiliyorum
2 ve 3 e geçelim diğer soruya bir ülke
nüfusunun yaş gruplarına göre dağılışını
gösteren nüfus piramidi 50 yıllık arayla
birinci şekilden ikinci şekle
dönüşmüştür ülke bundan buna geçmiş
bakın doğumlar fazlayken doğumlar
azalmaya başlamış Buna göre ülke ile
ilgili olarak aşağıdaki hangisi
söylenemez Aslında ülke biraz gelişmeye
gitmiş değil mi gelişmeye başlamış ülke
geçmişe göre doğum oranları azalmıştır
bakın doğumlar çok fazla doğumlar
azalmış Evet tamam çocuk nüfusun toplam
nüfus içindeki oranı azalmıştır Evet
bakın çocuk nüfusun oranı toplam nüfusta
fazlaymış geçmişte Ama şu an çocuk
nüfusun oranı az Evet nüfus artış hızını
azaltmaya yönelik Politikalar
uygulanmıştır Evet gençler geçmişte
nüfus artış hızı fazlayken bakın nüfus
artış hızını azaltmaya yönelik politika
uygulanmış ki nüfus artış hızı azalmaya
başlamış doğru gelişmişlik düze
artmıştır Evet ülke gelişmeye başlamış
1ci piramitten 3 piramide geçmiş doğru
bebek ölüm oranı artmıştır yanlış Çünkü
bu ülke gelişmemiş bir ülke bir
gelişmemiş E sen 3'e gelişmeye
başlıyorsanız sağlık imkanları artar
yanlış cevap geçeğim diğer soruya 014
yaş arası ve 65 yaş üzeri gruba Bağımlı
nüfus denir gençler bakın şunu unutmayın
şu üste yaşlı nüfus demiştik ya biz
Şuraya da çocuk nüfus demiştik değil mi
bu notu al Bunlar Bağımlı nüfus yaşlı
Bağımlı nüfus çocuk Bağımlı nüfus nereye
bağımlılar aktif nüfusa Aktif nüfus
çalışıp bunlara bakıyor bağımlı
demelerinin nedeni bu yaşlılarda emekli
yine bağımlı Tamam ama yaşlı Bağımlı
nüfus nerede fazla olur Almanya gibi
gelişmiş ülkelerde yaşlı Bağımlı nüfus
olur çocuk Bağımlı nüfus da Somali gibi
gelişmemiş ülkelerde çocuk Bağımlı nüfus
olur değil mi genç Bağımlı nüfus
oranının yüksek olduğu bir ülke hemen
somutlayıcı
mış genç Bağımlı nüfus gençler nerede
fazladır Somali gibi ülkelerde Ben hep
bu Somali ile Almanya'yı örnek veririm
böyle
somutluk yorumlarsınız somut Dadım
Somali dedim Bak şimdi hangisi
söylenemez Somali Somali'de kişi başına
düşen milli gelir azdır değil mi Evet
insanlar kişi başına düşen milli gelir
azdır Somali'de ortalama yaşam süresi Aa
Somali'de ortalama yaşam uzun mudur
insanlar yaşayamıyor ki olmaz uzun değil
bak Sanayi gelişmemiştir Somali'de doğru
Aktif nüfus oranı düşüktür Somali'de
doğru daha çok çocuk nüfus vardır Çünkü
gelişmemiş bir ülkedir Evet Somali gibi
ülkeler gelişmemiş ülkeler Evet cevap
Bursa geçelim diğer soruya demografik
dönüşüm sürecinin 4 aşamasında yer alan
bir ülke için yorumlarından hangileri
yapılamaz şimdi Birinci aşamada neydi
tek tek çizelim bunları böyle çizmeyi
öğren 1 1ci aşamada kenarları içe Çökük
dü değil mi İkinci aşamada düzgün bir
üçgene dönüşüyordu 3ün aşamada asimetrik
olacaktı düzgün üçgende problem
doğumların fazlalığı ydı doğumları
azaltacaktır şöyle Keskin bir düşüş
oluyordu doğumlarda düncü aşamad İsa
biraz daha şöyle doğumların azaldığı
yaşlı nüfusun arttığı arı kovanı
diyorduk biz buna geçmişte şöyle bir
daha doğumların az olduğu bir yapı
ortaya çıkıyordu 5ci aşamad İsa nüfusun
azaldığı artık Yukarıdaki yaş nüfusun
iyice şiştiği ama doğumların da iyice
düştüğü şöyle bir aşama çıkıyordu Buna
göre yorum yapacaksın bize ne diyor 4
aşama şuna göre yorum yap diyor
gelişmişlik seviyesinin yüksek olduğu
Evet Gençler bu 4 ve 5 gelişmiş
ülkelerdir Tamam Bunlar gelişmişlik
seviyesi yüksektir doğru nüfus artış
hızının çok düşük olduğu Evet bak 4te
nüfus artış hızı çok düşüktür çok
düşüktür Çünkü doğumlar çok az 5te nüfus
azalmaya başlamıştır ikisi arasındaki
fark bu tamam mı nüfus Artık yaşlılar
ölüyor doğumlarda az nüfus azalıyordu
Evet bu da doğru nüfusun giderek
gençleştiği Hayır yanlış nüfus
yaşlanıyor nüfus yaşlanıyor çocuk yok ki
cevap 1 ve 2 hangisi yapılam diyor özür
dilerim Bunlar yapılabilir yapılamaz 3
cevap C geçelim diğer soruya bir ülkenin
nüfus piramidi incelendiğinde
bilgilerinden hangilerine ulaşılabilir
şöyle bir piramit çizelim kendimize
şöyle bakalım toplam nüfus içinde genç
nüfus oranına şurası genç değil miydi
Şura üstü yaşlı ortası aktifti şurası
yaşlıydı öğren bunları şurası Aktif
nüfus şurası da genç nüfus O zaman ben
toplam nüfus içerisindeki gençlerin
oranını bulabilir miyim bulabilirim
Nüfusun yaş gruplarına dağılışını
bulabilirim E zaten piramitler bize 0 4
yaştan başlayıp 90 artıya kadar
gidiyordu yaşları gösteriyordu o zaman
yaşları da bulabilirim piramitten tarım
sektöründe çalışan nüfusun miktarına ne
kadarı kaç tanesi tarımda çalışıyor Bunu
nereden bilebilirim ki piramide bakarak
bulamam değil mi cevap hangisine
ulaşılır 1 ve 2 Denizli geçelim diğer
testimiz bir ülkede Nüfusun yaş
gruplarına göre dağılışı Son 20 yıl
içerisinde birinci şekilden ikinci şekle
dönüşmüştür a Bakın bu nasıl üçgen
Piramidi üçgenden bazen böyle yarım
gösterebilir Kafanız karışmasın üçgenden
neye dönüşmüş Aa son yıllarda nüfus
politikalarıyla doğum oranlarını
azalttığı ikinci şekilden 3üncü dönüşüm
modelindeki 3üncü kısma dönüşmüş doğum
oranlarının hızla azaldığı bir ülkeye
Gelişmekte olan ülkeye dönüşmüş Nüfusun
yaş gruplarına göre dağılışında meydana
gelen Bu değişmeye etmenlerinden
hangilerinin neden olduğu söylenebilir
niye böyle bir değişim yaşanmış Çünkü
bakın doğum oranları azalmış doğum
oranları azaldığı için böyle dönüşmüş bu
yani cevabımız a şıkı geçelim diğer
soruya yukarıdakilerden hangileri Bir
ülkenin gelişmişlik düzeyi hakkında
bilgi vermez bakalım
yorumlayabileceğinizi
nüfusun artış hızı çok fazlaysa bir
ülkede He bu ülke gelişmemiş Somali gibi
diyebiliriz değil mi nüfus artış hsı
fazla nüfus artış hsı azsa H Almanya
gibi gelişmiş ülkelerde nüfus artış hızı
azdı bakın gelişmişlik gelişmemişti
yorumu yapabildin mi yaptım değil mi o
zaman tikat nüfusun ülke içinde dağılışı
Ya bunu mesela ülkenin nüfus batıya
yerleşmiş ülkedeki nüfus doğuya
yerleşmiş o zaman gelişmiş batıya
yerleşmişse gelişmemiş böyle bir yorum
yapabilir miyiz yapamayız Olur mu öyle
şey nüfusun yoğunluğu ya bir ülkede
nüfus çok yoğun Yani yoğunluktan
kastımız kilometre kareye düşen insan
sayısı kilometrekareye düşen insan
sayısı çok fazlaysa bak kilometreye
düşen insan sayısı nüfusun miktarı falan
onlar bunlar değil hiçbir şey değil
kilometreye düşen insan sayısı nüfus
yoğunsa gelişmiştir bu ülke nüfus
seyrekse gelişmemiştir böyle bir yorum
yapılabilir mi E Japonya bir aday Ülkesi
dar alanları var nüfus da kalabalık
yoğun gelişmiş bir ülke e Çin'de de
nüfusun yoğun olduğu birçok yer var ama
o o kadar gelişmiş değil yoğunluğa
bakarak gelişmiş gelişmemiş yorumu
yapamayız nüfusun niteliği nitelikten
kastımız eğitim seviyesi nüfusun eğitim
seviyesine bakarak gelişmiştir
gelişmemiştir diyebiliriz değil mi
Hangisi vermez e 2 ve 3 bize fikir
vermez cevap C geçelim diğer soruya
Gelişmekte olan bir ülkede meydana
gelecek aşağıdaki değişikliklerden
hangisi bu ülkenin gelişmiş ülke
durumuna geçmekte olduğunun göstergesi
olamaz Gelişmekte olan bir ülkey demiş
tamam mı Ne yapalım Gelişmekte olan bir
ülke Gelişmekte olan Türkiye diyelim Bu
diyor gelişmiş ülke durumuna geçmekte
olduğunun göstergesi olamaz hammadde dış
alımının artması bu gelişmiş ülkenin
özelliğidir dışarıdan gelişmiş ülkeler
hammadde alır onu İşler dışarıya
işlenmiş bir şekilde satar bu gelişmiş
ülkelerin özelliği Bak bu gelişmiş ülke
özelliği nüfus piramidinin taban
kısmının genişlemesi nüfus piramidinin
taban kısmı genişlerse O zaman ne olur e
taban kısmı genişlerse gelişmemiş ülkeye
doğru gider o zaman bu
gelişmemiş ülkeye ait enerji tüketiminin
artması bu gelişmiş ülkenin özelliğidir
Neden Çünkü Almanya gibi gelişmiş
ülkelerde bir süre elektronik alet
olduğu için her şey elektronik olduğu
için enerji tüketimi fazladır enerji
tüketimi geliş gelmiş ülkelerde artar
gelişmiş ülke özelliği nitelikli iş gücü
gereksiniminin artması bak iş gücü
kaliteli iş gücüne ihtiyaç gelişmiş
ülkelerde olur Almanya gibi gelişmiş
ülkelerde kaliteli kendini yetiştirmiş
iş gücüne ihtiyaç vardır Somali'de iş
gücüne ihtiyaç var mı kaliteli iş gücüne
yaşam düzeyinin yükselmesi Almanya
gibi ülkelerde gelişmiş ülkelerde yaşam
düzeyinin yükselmesi vardır ama nüfus
piramidinin taban kısmı gelişmemiş
ülkeye ait Yani cevabımız b geçelim
diğer soru aşağı grafikte bir ülkede
kadın ve erkek nüfusunun yaş gruplarına
göre dağılımı gösterilmiştir bakın
milyon kişi vermiş Böyle grafikleri
verildiğinde buna bir dikkat edin tamam
mı milyon kişi demek ki bize ne vermiş
miktar vermiş miktara bakarak oran
bulabiliriz Biz Tamam ama Orana bakarak
miktar bulamıyoruz bunun notunu böyle al
65 yaş üzerindeki kadınların sayısı
erkeklerden fazladır bize milyon kişi
verdiği için Şuradaki 65 yaşı bulup
bunların kadın sayısına bakıp bakın
kadın sayısı erkeklerinkinden fazladır
kadınlar pembe Evet Kadınlar erkeklerden
fazladır Doğru mu Doğru genç nüfus
içinde erkeklerin Payı daha fazladır
genç nüfus neredeydi şuraya kadardı 14
yaşa kadardı bakıyorum şimdi genç nüfus
erkek fazla erkek fazla erkek fazla
gördük mü Doğru bakın piramidin nasıl
yorumlandığını öğrenin 50 54 yaş
arasındaki nüfus 2 milyondan fazladır
5054 yaş şurası 2 milyondan fazla mı
bakalım bize milyon kişi verdiği için
oran vermiş olsaydı şöyle O zaman ben
buna sayı 2 milyondan fazladır azdır
diyemezdim Çünkü oran vermişti bana ama
milyon verdiği için sayıyı bulabilirim
5054 yaş şurada bakın Şurada şöyle
geldim 1 milyon Aa 1 milyon diyor ama
bakın erkek 1 milyon erkek 1 milyon e
kadın da 1 milyondan Bir tık daha fazla
1 milyon artı diyelim e 2 milyondan
fazla Demek ki Anladık mı mantığı
ikisini toplayacaksın kadın ve erkeek
bir çizgide vermiş bize Evet bu da doğru
kadın nüfus erkek nüfustan fazladır
bakalım bunun için toplamamız gerekecek
ama kabaca da olsa bakabiliriz erkek
fazla erkek fazla erkek fazla şurada
eşitler eşitler eşitler erkek fazla
erkek fazla erkek fazla eşitler kadınlar
şuralarda Bir tık daha fazla ama erkeğin
fazla olduğu yer daha fazla olduğu için
erkekler daha fazladır Burada ne diyor
kadın nüfus erkekten fazladır diyor
Hayır erkeklerin daha fazla olduğunu
gördük biz yanlış oldu tamam cevap D
geçelim diğer soruya bir ülkenin
gelişmişlik düzeyini belirleyen gösterge
Nüfusun yaş yapısı kabul edilirse
aşağıdaki nüfus piramitleri ve verilen
beş ülkeden hangisinin daha az geliştiği
söylenebilir Bakın şimdi şuu yapmış bak
doğumlar fazlaymış son yıllarda
doğumları azaltıyor 3üncü piramit bu
bakın şuna bu üçgen Piramidi düzgün
üçgen piramidine benziyor üçgen Bu
ikinci piramit kenarları içe Çökük
olsaydı 1 olurdu Başka şuraya bakıyorum
burada ortanca yaş biraz artmış şurada
bir azalma var ama ortay yca yaş biraz
yüksek yaşlılar da biraz fazla geldi
bana o zaman bunu Yani biraz daha 4E
koyarız gibi de geliyor bana Aslında 3
ile 4 arasında ama şurada bir doğumlarda
azalma olduğu için yani Bunu tam bir
kısma koyamıyoruz ama tam gelişmemiş de
diyemiyoruz buna şuraya bakın doğumlar
resmen azalmış bu 5 ülke Piramidi ydi
değil mi Yaşlar almış başını gitmiş bu
ne ya böyle doğumlar sıfırlanacak nyse
bu beşinci Şu 4 desek bu 5 falan olur
tam birbirine bazen oturmaya bilir ama
bunların gelişmiş olduğu belli bunların
en az gelişmiş olanı doğumların en fazla
olduğu c şıkkı olur geçelim diğer soruya
aşağıda Türkiye nüfusunun 2020 yılı
nüfus piramidi gösterilmiştir Türkiye
nüfusunun yaş yapısı ile ilgili aşağıdak
hangisi söylenemez Gençler bu direkt
üniversite sınavında çıkma ihtimali olan
bir sorudur bakın bize ne vermiş oran
vermiş bu Orana piramitleri gördüğünüzde
hemen ilk çizeceğiniz şey aynı benim
yaptığım gibi ha bu Oran Oran vermiş O
zaman ben Bunda sayı hakkında yorum
yapam yapam Tamam kadın ve erkek nüfus
miktar miktar diyor bak sayı miktar
hakkında yorum yapamam dedim ama
buradaki miktar direkt miktarı sormamış
deseydi ki işte şu kadar miktar vardır
bu kadar miktar vardır O zaman sıkıntı
olurdu ama bakın buradaki tam miktar
gibi de değil bu kadın ve erkek nüfus
miktarı birbirine yakındır Ya sen şimdi
kabaca baktığında e kadın ve erkek e
birbirine yakın ya miktar kelimesi
sadece ald aldatıcı bir şekilde koyulmuş
oraya miktar kelimesini aldatmak için
koymuş kadın ve erkek nüfusu birbirine
yakındır e kabaca baktığımda görüyorum
bunu o zaman bunu çıkartabilirim nüfus
piramidinin taban kısmının durağ
anlaşmaya başlaması doğum oranının
azalmaya başladığını gösterir Evet bakın
doğum oranları azalmaya başlamış doğru
şöyle doğru yazalım erkeklerde nüfusun
en fazla olduğu yaş grubu 40 44
kadınlarda 30 34'ten de nüfusun en fazla
olduğu 40 44 demiş Aa öyle değil bakın
erkeklerde nüfusu en fazla olduğu şurası
20 24 yanlış olmuş kadınlarda 35 39
bakın 35 39 yanlış 334 demiş yanlış bu
yanlışı bulduk nüfusun yarıdan fazlası
40 yaşın altındadır şöyle kabaca bir
bakarsak Ne oluyor ya buna Ha şöyle Evet
bakın yarıdan fazlası 40 yaşın altında
yaşlı nüfus oranı düşüktür Evet bakın
daha çok şuralarda genç ve Aktif nüfus
fazla yaşlı nüfus oranı oranı düşük Evet
oranını vermiş doğru cevap C geçelim
diğer soruya 014 yaş aralığındaki nüfus
ile 65 ve üzeri nüfusa Bağımlı nüfus
denir gelişmiş ülkelerde yaşlı Bağımlı
nüfus gelişmemiş ülkelerde ise genç
Bağımlı nüfus oranı fazladır Bunu
anlatmıştım sana aşağıda nüfus
piramidinde verilen ülkelerin hangisinde
yaşlı Bağımlı nüfus daha fazladır yaşlı
bağımlı demek yaşlılar fazla olacak
gelişmiş ülkelerde yaşlılar fazlaydı
değil mi Almanya gibi gelişmiş ülke
Piramidi lazım bize bakalım piramit
gelişmemiş ülke Piramidi Gelişmekte olan
gelişmemiş ülke Piramidi bakın yaşlı
nüfusun en fazla olduğu yer yaşlı
bağımlı nüfusun en fazla olduğu yer
burası burada doğumlar da azalmış yaşlar
artmış gelişmiş ülke Piramidi cevapçı
geçelim diğer soruya 2023 yılı nüfusu
ile ilgili aşağıda verilen bilgilerden
hangisi Türkiye'nin Gelişmekte olan bir
ülke olduğuna Kanıt oluşturmaz yaşam
süresi her yıl artarsa bu gelişmiş ülke
özelliğidir nüfusun ortanca yaşı 34'e
yükselmiştir yani ortanca yaş yani yaşlı
nüfus demek utanca yaşımızın ortada
kalan kısmı yükseliyor ülke yaşlanıyor o
gelişmiş ülke özelliğidir nüfus
yoğunluğunun 111 kişi olması gençler
nüfus yoğunluğu gelişmiştir
gelişmemiştir yorumu
yaptırmıyorsa gelişmiş ülkedir diyorduk
o zaman gelişmiş ülke özelliği Yetişkin
ve yaşlı nüfus oranı artarken genç nüfus
oranı azalıyorsa Bu da gelişmiş ülke
özelliği gelişmiş ülkelerde genç nüfus
azdır cevap C Evet testi de bitirmiş
olduk Evet gençler nüfus piramitlerini
de demografik dönüşüm modelini de
öğrendik şimdi yazılıya gidebilirsiniz
yazılı ile alakalı size genel tekrarda
yaptığım yazılı örneğe çözümü de Onları
izlemeden sınava girmiyorsun ne diyoruz
o zaman Yunus hocayla bir defa öğren bir
daha asla unutma zedu ile eğitim her
yerde